welcome everyone to another exciting
edition of the NBA on 2k sports they've
been great about about working with me
and trying to make sure that we get the
kind of cadence that's necessary to make
it sound like it's a real game and and
again the brilliance of the people that
to put the game together able to make
that work and sound like it's this real
broadcast which is amazing to me Chris
the frontcourt matchup it's Britney and
drinking tonight it's gonna be a lot
more contact fishing she'll be battling
for position is not a place for the
faint of heart and direct gives you such
a huge target on aliens honey just
beautiful harden is so good at finishing
these hand ones I mean he is just a
thorn in the d-side how's that for in
your face tremont shrug it off the
defensive throat Smitty great dad you in
the booth here a former NBA all-star NBA
champion is a different dynamic getting
a chance to obviously broadcast and play
now mixing both of them and get a chance
to be a voice of the game so I'm excited
when you were a young player in the
league and taking on the great legends
of the 90s were there any games where
you were just in awe of who you were on
the court facing a lot Kevin but some
names that come to mind was first
Michael Jordan's going up against the
great Michael Jordan a lot of people say
they played against Michael but he
I love seeing Chris Paul come alive on
these possessions one of the top ball
handlers in this league Kyrie can make
you look all right foolish Paul George I
like the way a pull-up jump shots at his
size none of those other ones which run
put on the brakes and fire away I was
never one of those guys I didn't have
good brakes hit your brakes you're not
evidence breaks it breaks around nope
god I don't have these teams are having
a hard time coming up with winds Brent
can a losing streak like this get in the
team's head oh I can get in your head it
can give you a car it can get into your
jeans it's all over the place Kevin so
you know one good game can turn around a
month of your season one good month can
turn around your entire season we'll see
if it starts here tonight I think the
way that 2k goes about making this game
the type of consideration that they have
they get it right Lillard's i'm outside
drills the three pointer keep thinking
that he can't shoot it from there and
you'll prove you're wrong Lillard mocks
one of those high arching bombs oh he
blocks it off the glass wow phenomenal
defense by Anthony Davis to spike that
shot back Oh in the foot back
you love the effort from Whiteside there
to stay after it and slam that one back
off the Miss look at the players Doris a
little extra bounce and their stuff I
would say oh no quite this is what we've
all been waiting for quote the
friendlies are no longer the club's have
come off it's time to perform it's no
different than when I'm doing the job on
TV and people are fabulous they make the
experience fun and engaging karl-anthony
towns again this is one of the better
catch and shoot pigs in the NBA already
towns doing everything these days
looking like a running back in the open
field what's so always a threat to
convert in transition you know that's
just the power and strength from anthony
able to take the hit and still play
through it oh what a play by sinan can't
shake simmons he is very used to getting
hit just plays right through the contact
and with a room he can store from
anywhere it is jump shot is money
and his drives to the hoop but their
reason David Aldridge is on our side
line thank you Kevin guys Chicago is one
of the league's biggest markets but it
still has that blue-collar culture take
a listen to a recent huddle from coach
Billy Donovan we got a chance to get a
great road win right now go passing the
ball great to start keep pushing the
tempo get back sent our defense it's our
energy the gutters back in the day right
now is when we talk on every screen down
here we can't miss us out and give up to
lay out it can't happen hey we had a
good start we can get right back on it
every time we got to get back and
stopped the basketball we welcome you
back Ernie Johnson along with Shaq and
Kenny with this one in the books we've
got a special postgame guest joining us
how did you get in that con his own ah
you know I don't think it was really
about me at all man I'll happy are you
with the way you guys battle inside I'm
pretty happy man you know we want to be
a team that sets the tone by the way we
attack the glass did you feel you with
BBQ chicken trying to guard you down
there on the post of course I did Shaq
come on son you gotta feed the hot hand
and that's usually me you don't I'm
saying Kenny i dunno what you're saying
but the hot hand can't be grieving my
man ha what's going through the players
uh yeah right i was outside to be here
all the hard work that they put into the
season has led up to this hey cuz
they're on a quest list to be the best
yes to reap the final destination
destination again because no matter what
no matter what the team's d me to be
congratulated crack you later for making
it this far
they make it this far baby for making it
this far they making it this far hey
Kevin back to you